james canucko how are you guys today
good great exciting
yeah i'm excited too i'm fantastic thank
you uh i'm really excited too because so
i watched all of the episodes
and uh i i truly enjoyed how refreshing
visions was i liked how different it was
i like the change of pace there's some
episodes in there that i i really really
truly love so uh congratulations on this
because i think it's gonna be a big hit
with a lot of people um james right off
the bat i want to start with you i know
we don't have so much time but i truly
did love some of these
the style of some of these episodes i
love the storytelling i think it was
different than some of the star wars
that we have before since you're
involved with so many projects that are
upcoming i was wondering if visions
affected the pun intended here vision of
any other upcoming project storytelling
wise or cinematography wise
uh i mean the unexciting answer of that
is
not
as of now i i think it will is is
nothing being planned but i think every
good piece of star wars inspires future
creators and i i think we're all really
proud we think this came out really well
i think there's like an amazing array of
ideas in here that um we just haven't
seen in star wars before so i think it
will inspire uh creators to one day and
you know i don't think it's gonna
directly change the trajectory of um the
star wars franchise but i do think it it
opens up a door for really cool
exploration and really cool opportunity
to to see star wars expressed in
different ways and who knows where
uh you know those ideas will go in star
wars i mean
so much of uh things in the past have
that we've done have found their way
into our storytelling you know and i
think that happens with just really
interesting imaginative creators working
in the franchise
well and i hope it does because it was
really creative and it was different
storytelling so i do hope that
eventually down the line at some point
in time it does kind of bleed into that
a little bit uh kanako my question is
for you now i know the duel the first
episode is getting
a novel title ronan um i was curious
because there's episodes like episode
three the twins in episode seven um the
elder which i really really loved they
kind of lead us to believe there might
be a follow-up episode maybe down the
line maybe if there's a season two what
are the chances that we could get some
of these follow-up episodes
and is there gonna be a season two
it would be great but i think we like we
love to hear first like a fan's reaction
like from the week from now and see how
much they will be excited as we are
right now
and like like you uh bring it up the
duels has
ronin is such an interesting character
that there's so much room to explore
that's why there is a publishing and
ronin novel coming out from delray
and to explore like his uh journey in
the galaxy so yeah like i'd love to see
uh
i'm sure the creator have more to tell
or like i'm sure they have some
backstory
not telling in the shorts so
yeah like we'd love to hear that at some
point
yeah i i would love to
see what the fans think as well i think
the fans are gonna really really enjoy
this because i do think it is so
different and refreshing um so fingers
crossed for season two because i would
like to see some of those stories played
out um i was curious for the both of you
um are you big anime fans yourself and
did any personal anime preferences
perhaps bleed into the show a little bit
uh can i though we can start with you
um i
i do love anime and then like i think
i because i grew up in japan so
i have like a different perspective to
the anime itself
and
what stick to me more is like what i saw
when i was really small so that's the
biggest memory i have would be a shaw
account which is like sherlock holmes
story but the older character is a dog
and that's like
miyazaki so like i grabbed these type of
anime so like yeah but it doesn't really
affect what we did for divisions but i'd
love to see like how much anime uh
changed or developed from like 30 years
ago to now because like expression
changed so much and it's great to see
like all the uh yeah the
the revolutions from like early 50s to
here
yeah it's big change um i know we're out
of time but james any uh comment on that
about your own anime preferences
absolutely fan and i think that's what
what has driven a a lot of this on our
side is that that there's tons of fans
at lucasfilm and i'm working in this
anthology or many of the studios that
i've been a huge fan of for since
probably the early 90s if you know so uh
yeah
new
studios that are coming up
we watch everything and are always
inspired by great
animation and cinematic storytelling so
um
you know yes is is the answer
fantastic i love that and i i think it
was fantastic so whatever inspirations
y'all drew from for this i think it
turned out perfectly i really really
enjoyed it congratulations to the both
of you thank you so much for your time
today it was a pleasure thank you warren
good to hear that thank you very much
take care